I wanna talk about Europe because while
I'm here I'm not here a long time I'm
trying to experience all the greatest
things about this city now one of them
and we've been doing that this week one
of them is getting to play basketball at
the legendary Street Court in the
village it's called the cage you've
probably all been down there you've seen
it
legendary all of the best street players
get together there and they play hoops
okay now I like playing basketball I'm
pretty good ignore that I just did that
it's proof look at that Hey look it
looked like you were pushing away a girl
bully
[Applause]
anyway it's legendary it's legendary to
play ball down there so why you headed
downtown for some classic New York
Street ball and ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
[Music]
so basketball didn't work out so well
but as you may know New York has some of
the best chess players in the country
seriously you can get some of the best
pickup chess games down in Washington
Square Park I love chess myself I'm
pretty good
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so I headed down to the park for a
little game of chess take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
you